than Affleck River Tam obscene a pattern
[Music]
the accountant the accountant stars Ben
Affleck basically Ben Affleck is
autistic in this movie that makes him
very good with numbers so there are some
dangerous people out there that hire him
to uncook their books but it also makes
them very good at killing people
I guess so now we have a movie about an
autistic badass accountant who kills
people a day Ben Affleck has continually
proven himself against the Affleck
haters out there the dude's a great
actor he's a great director guys legit
he was great in this movie he totally
commits to this role of this autistic
dude it's just kind of awkward around
people is very matter-of-fact but also
badass that is a hard line to walk if it
dude walks it for someone who has so few
words and is so soft-spoken you
shouldn't actually gravitate towards the
dude and be like I don't want to see
what you do next but you totally do the
movie generally is kind of hard to say
what the movies about because it's not
just about an accountant who is also a
good killer who's autistic know there
are a lot of subplots in the movie and
that's one of the movie's flaws is that
the fact that there's so much going on
everything feels like a subplot even the
things that should have been a main plot
what's it about is about Ben Affleck
trying to trace the money in this one
company is that about Anna Kendrick
getting attached to Ben Affleck is it
about JK Simmons wanting to find this
accountant using this girl to do it I
mean that should have been a huge pot
this movie it was very minimal to use
now this isn't me griping about the
movie I was thoroughly entertained in
the accountant what the accountant does
is get you attached to Ben Affleck's
character you're interested in him and
his condition how that feeds into his
life and how it makes him a good badass
she's surprisingly so so when the movie
does slow down and it does slow down
often you're still interested in how he
handles situations and how he uses his
autism to his advantage however when I
say the movie slows down I really mean
it this movie does drag on in a couple
scenes and starts to slow down you're
like okay just move how long we've been
here movie feels longer than it actually
is movie is about two hours long there's
a scene where these two characters are
talking about this accountant who he is
what he's done he gets to the point
where he's just fire balling things that
this dude has done he did this this this
mist that was crazy he also did this
this isn't this you don't get the point
by now he's done this does this and you
feel like they probably wanted to show
these events
happiness prominent events in this film
however they probably realized like at
that point the movie will probably feel
like seven hours and already feels like
three so they were omitted you like
learning it you like learning about this
dude however it's a bit on the nose like
they just might as well have talked to
the audience but all right guys this is
what this guy's done now you know
however the last act of the movie really
picks up as most of this movie is Ben
Affleck chasing numbers in a book and
living that live that aspect of his
world the last act is when he goes full
like oh yeah I'm also a badass mode it
was really exciting I wish the movie was
more evenly balanced with the two woven
throughout but it really is like a lot
of this here some of this hair however I
was thoroughly entertained by the
accountant for most of the accountant I
was interested in Ben Affleck's
character and I do enjoy it when a movie
shows you one side of someone for so
long and then he flips that switch like
yeah I'm also like this watch out the
movies a little slow pacing wise now you
know that if that's not your thing still
consider yourself informed I will say
the accountant was a good time no
alcohol required and this video is
brought to you by loot crate enter promo
code Jeremy Jones or follow the link
below to save yourself 10% the October
theme is horror because it's October
that I imagine they would do that makes
sense than they did as we all love scary
things you have until October 19th to
get your horror crate after that you
miss it and no one wants to miss some
horror so as I said follow the link
below to save yourself 10% on some loot
crate horror crate alright guys - the
accountant have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]